son ordinateur n'est jamais loin d'elle
edville cffers cette mansonienne
étudiante en 2e année de thèse à
l'Université de Lille tente de créer une
intelligence artificielle respectueuse
de la vie privée j'essaye de développer
des méthodes qui garantissent de façon
certaine que personne ne peut juste en
interagissant avec lia en posant des
questions reconstruire les données qui
ont été utilisées pour l'entraînement un
cas qui peut notamment s'appliquer au
domaine médical là c'est un exemple
d'intelligence artificielle qui est en
train d'apprendre à reconnaître des
objets donc ici par exemple une table et
ce qu'on peut voir c'est que nous sans
avoir accès à la donnée juste en
regardant comment elle apprend c'est
possible de reconstruire l'image donc on
part d'un point au hasard et petit à
petit en enlevant le bruit on reconnaît
entièrement la table et à la place de
cette table on pourrait imaginer
n'importe quelle autre image par exemple
dans le domaine médical on pourrait
avoir la photo d'un scanner et donc
reconstruire toute l'image du scanner y
compris les coordonnées de la personne
qui peuvent être marqué sur le côté
siedvich s'est attelé à ses recherches
c'est pour lutter contre certaines
dérives de l'intelligence artificielle
gourmand en données et notamment en
données personnelles les algorithmes
peuvent constituer un risque pour les
sociétés et les individus pourvig
recevoir le Prix Jeune Talent L'Oréal
UNESCO dans un milieu masculin est une
marque de reconnaissance et aussi un
levier financier pour lui permettre de
financer ses recherches
c'est à l'Institut Necker enfant malade
dans le 15e arrondissement de Paris que
travaille une deuxième lauréate
ivelinoise Aurore Claude Topin habitante
de poignille Laforêt cette chercheuse
postdoctorante est revenue des
États-Unis il y a 3 ans pour faire de la
recherche dans le domaine de la
cancérologie où elle étudie
l'autophagie donc c'est un processus qui
est utilisé par toutes les cellules dont
les cellules cancéreuses pour pouvoir
produire de l'énergie quand elles en ont
besoin quand elles sont sont dans des
situations défavorables donc c'est le
cas des cellules cancéreuses elles sont
en conditions défavorables elles vont
essayer de utiliser l'autophagie pour
produire de l'énergie survivre jusqu'à
ce que les conditions soient meilleures
pour pouvoir faire des des métastases
par exemple éviter le risque de rechute
par métastase c'est l'objectif d'Aurore
mais si elle a reçu le Prix de la
Fondation l'uréal UNESCO c'est notamment
parce qu'elle utilise un système invitro
pour éviter l'expérimentation animale
durant cette étape clé alors le système
que j'utilise quotidiennement pour
pouvoir mimer in vitro le transport des
cellules métastatiques dans les
vaisseaux sanguins et ça ça nous permet
d'utiliser moins de de de souris et
d'animaux pour notre projet pour Aurore
le Prix Jeune Talent L'Oréal UNESCO
c'est l'occasion de briser le plafond de
verre dans la recherche mais aussi de
porter une voix pour les étudiants qui
ont comme elle un parcours atypique
c'est OK de faire une filière
technologique et professionnalisante et
c'est même surtout un atout pour pour le
après parce qu'on sait vraiment dans
quel monde on se lance parce que j'ai pu
découvrir le monde de la recherche grâce
à mes stages de BTS cette année le
concours récompense aussi Ophélie
mintoch originaire du chénérocour elle
est spécialisée dans l'astrobiologie et
mène des recherches sur la présence de
matière organique sur la planète Mars
auatmos à Saint-Quentin en Yveline et à
l'INAF